yeah what's the worst parts of the job
that you get that kind of stuff is
people telling you like yeah just being
they always tell you oh yeah you know I
pay your salary so I we always used to
keep like nickels and dimes in the truck
and I'd be like hold on I'll give you
your money back because they would
always say like all right each person
gives you a nickel a year or and I would
throw the nickel at them here here's
your money the [__] out of my face you
got to take this the guy's whole
apartment's out there yeah it's like
dude go no and I would always respect
the person to come out if you just said
Thank you or even gave a water cuz you
know you weren't supposed to take money
and all that stuff if you just said
Thank you and acknowledge me like I said
that we were you know everybody nobody
knew us thank you went a long way with
me I take everything I don't care you
know but when you look at me like oh I
pay your salary and look down to me yeah
yeah go [__] yourself yeah agreed your
stuff would stay there for months oh
yeah I'll [__] put it back in your
house yeah I'll throw it right back on
your curb the white elephant that's what
they call it and the white elephant
always got in people's way really piss
them off oh yeah you guys are the worst
dude I used to do the whole Hogan real
quick I used to do that I us take my
gloves off and they bang you know in
Manhattan and I'd be
like you're an [__] I'm like you
should have woke up 10 minutes early cuz
now you're stuck behind me and I ain't
moving well the craziest thing about a
about a sanitation truck is that not
only you stuck but it smells bad you're
[__] like he and they used to get
real close and and like I was saying
when the [__] used to spray out
especially rainy days after a rainy day
or or if it was raining wet days dude
that thing and the cars would get
covered i' be like oh well that's on you
dude you know you would have cars parked
so tight and there's 30 just saying a
smaller stop this 15 20 30 BS wow d i be
like oh sad day for this Jaguar owner I
would literally cuz I would tell you
know I was 21 I was stupid oh yeah I
would grab them both sides slide them
right across the h
a Jaguar whatever rich people dude yeah
whatever call was that bro I [__]
there was nothing better than doing
something to the [__] rich boy you
know well they just didn't care oh yeah
they had no respect for me so now it's
like all right oh cuz they parked
illegally they well no they parked
legally but they give you no space so
now those bags you know they're heavy
and I get it everybody would say well we
don't know we're not garbage men right
well now you're going to know yeah now
you got now you got to go to the body
shop yeah fix your [__] on your dime you
didn't see people yeah unless you were
you know waking people up and you know
in their way other than that they you
were not like it was crazy because
nobody even knew they never acknowledged
you wow you were there you picked a
garbage up you left you're kind of the
Invisible Man exactly you really are
because yeah nobody wants to get that
close people kind of want to pretend you
don't exist unless you're making noise
people don't engage yeah
you yeah you're kind of the Invisible
Man until they realize you were making
money and then sudden like oh look at
this Rich [__] ring through here guys
I got to put more garbage out yeah yeah
you know and then they would turn into
well it's your job you know pick this up
here take this you have to take this you
had that a lot you know people were very
you know people thought they owned you
yep yeah I pay your salary and all that
junk so [__] you in the suburbs it feels
like it would be a little bit easier is
it or not
in the listen when you get to the
suburbs now it turns into now you're
dealing with homeowners like when you
were in the buildings you were in the
buildings you had you didn't they didn't
care yeah you never saw them you know
never saw people it's not like hey I'm
I'm from 4f yeah you know you're an
idiot like they you know they don't care
Oh in a city you could just drive and
just yell out anyway yeah there's cabs
beeping like so you never you know
you're not waking anybody up everybody's
used to it right they come to s island
and you know even Queens areas like
Brooklyn areas now you're waking
everybody up it's 6:00 a.m. so who's
bitching about that um like I said
getting in the way yeah like there's
certain areas that we couldn't go in
like they make them pick up midnight to
like 5 so that you're not in their way
really so like what do you mean richer
areas no just owned areas by certain
types of people in okay so New York so
maybe upper echelon or whatever you
think not certain religion people they
have their so like the Orthodox Jews
don't want you in their neighborhood
between 12 to 5 Bingo wow and those are
some nasty mother is it pretty nasty
over there in their neighborhood well
they just listen it's nothing against
them CU I have actually been in some of
those houses yeah because they are there
are people in those areas that are very
nice but then you know Passover comes
and they throw everything out they're
like five six year olds throwing matches
like sh lighting [__] on fire
it was crazy I was like I can't do this
no more cuz they would bring everybody
pretty much who was available from other
garages to come and do this and you get
one truck on a block and you just go up
and down all day and they throw
everything out like I didn't know if you
knew that about the Orthodox Jews uh
they just get rid of everything they
throw everything out couches beds
clothes everything goes in the garbage
why it's just part of the tradition part
of their religion wow start fresh it's
just chaos so like it would be a garbage
truck every block and a in a fire truck
firemen would have like three blocks
because the kids running around like and
I had guys do it plenty of times they
light something on fire and then throw
it in the back of the truck now if I
don't see it now everything in the
truck's on fire why do they do that is
that like a kind of like a just uh are
they training for like battle or
something no it's just the kids oh kids
screwing around animals oh yeah oh so I
blocked a a bus one day and then that's
what I'm saying like then that's when
they get into we don't want them on the
truck uh the streets early this time
blah blah blah and these little kids get
off the buses cuz now I held them up on
the Block and they're blowing the horn
you know they have their own police
their own people and they tell you you
got to move the truck I'm like dude I'm
almost done with the block I'm not
moving the truck yeah the little kid
gets off and he's flicking me the finger
wow he's like five I'm like what are
they what go what goes on here they're
still they're doing you with service and
they always say everybody's always you
know lying was oh well I'm you know
that's their job they have to pick it up
they got to take it and I would tell
people this ain't my job you know I'm
here to pick up your household garbage
I'm not here to take all your demo from
your construction job on your house and
that was always where the fine line of
like arguing fighting with people like I
ain't going to fight with you it's
garbage like why are we fighting over
garbage right just get a dumpster and
I'm not picking this up yeah case
settled done yeah if somebody tried to
go to blows with you or something yeah a
few times women or men well the woman
the it was a husband and wife and they
had bags to tile out M and the bags and
get the [__] out of here with that she
was just an asshle this woman and
literally the tile is sticking out the
bag oh yeah so that's like razor blades
porcelain tile I don't know if you ever
been cut by porcelain it sucks and she's
like oh you're not going to take this
yeah it's your job I said listen this
I'm not taking the [__] you can throw it
in oh fine I'll throw it in yeah look
big strong guy you know uh sanitation
worker can't throw it in but I could and
she's rubbing it all up on her belly and
[__] I'm like good look at you you
animal you know turns out she's a nurse
oh yeah nursing a [__] biscuit all
morning that [__] [__] out of her mind
bro sorry that's kind of mean I'm
getting mean no and she says you know
and it was [__] up what she said she
was like you know you know what if you
ever come into my hospital and you need
help you know [__] you uh-uh I said you
know and now like I said I'm not a blow
my top it's garbage [__] well I'm not
going to fight with you you want to
throw it in throw it in I don't give a
[__] I said you know what [__] [__] you
yeah right to a face and I [__]
closed the hopper and she still had 10
15 bags left and I [__] drove away I
told my partner to
drive my boss calls he's like what are
you doing I said let me guess the nurse
called he's like I don't know who the
nurse is but this woman called and you
know she's calling she got 311 on the
line this and that and I'm like dude
this is what she said to me so I B my
lid and told her to go [__] herself yeah
he's like listen my boss calls he's like
just let her throw the rest of the bags
in I'm like I don't want to go back
there so we went back anyway wow cuz I
just don't want to deal with I don't
want to fight on my other end so I go
back to now her Burly 68 husband's there
uhuh and he gets in my face right and
I'm like dude you do not want to do this
I said listen I'm a garbage man that's
all fine and dandy but you don't want to
see what other part there is yeah my old
67y old partner jumps out the truck gets
right in his face starts pushing him
he's like dude you get the [__] back in
the house we'll throw the [__] in get
the [__] out of my partner's face yeah I
was like good for you yeah good for you
but you had that here and there yeah
people want to fight it's garbage what
are we fighting over garbage
for